über den zustand ist bereits heraus
gedrungen dass der leichten
schüttelfrost und leichtes fieber hat
husten und eine verstopfte nase also
klassische corona symptome was
allerdings besorgniserregend ist ist
dass wir gestern erst von der infektion
erfahren haben gestern war der test
positiv und heute wurde er bereits
eingeliefert viele experten sagen
normalerweise dauert es etwas länger der
krankheitsverlauf bis die symptome dann
auch stärker werden wenn sie stärker
werden also da gibt es einige leute die
sich jetzt sorgen machen auf der anderen
seite sagen viele erst der präsident der
usa da werden natürlich alle
vorsichtsmaßnahmen ergriffen und da
sieht man ihn lieber im krankenhaus
direkt sollte was sein dass man sofort
reagieren kann
trotzdem lass uns da noch mal darauf
einsteigen weil krankenhaus das hört
sich ja jetzt erst einmal schlimmer nach
einem statement hört sich das an was hat
das zu bedeuten kann so dass trotzdem
noch mal sagen dass trump jetzt ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert wurde
also es ist natürlich immer mehr als
besorgniserregend wenn der präsident im
krankenhaus ist man weiß dass der
gesundheitszustand der präsidentin immer
viel anlass für spekulationen lässt dass
die der ängste starb auch immer sehr
zurückhaltend ist mit wirklichen
nachrichten und wie fakten zum
gesundheitszustand das hat man in der
vergangenheit gesehen
woodrow wilson hat nach einem
schlaganfall war der wirklich halbseitig
gelähmt das hat man versucht zu
verheimlichen weiß schon dass kennedy
weiß man dass also weiß man heute dass
sein gesundheitszustand wesentlich
schlechter war als das was man zu der
zeit immer vorgegeben hat er massive
rückenschmerzen hat wirklich starke
tabletten genommen all das wurde vor der
allgemeinheit zurückgehalten einfach
weil man natürlich niemanden
verunsichern will auch bei regen der
damals ja opfer eines attentats wurde
war nicht sofort klar wie knapp er
eigentlich dem tod entkommen ist also da
muss man vorsichtig sein mit auch fakten
und und statements die herausdrängen
aber was man jetzt gesehen hat ist trump
konnte noch relativ munter sein
statement geben bevor er ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert wurde
er ist auch selbst gelaufen dh
beobachter eben auch gesagt das ist ein
gutes zeichen also er musste jetzt nicht
mit also mit notfall sanitätern
eingeliefert werden also er sah es war
wirklich mehr nach einer
vorsichtsmaßnahme aus